up against your body.
Whoa.
It's bigger than John.
Hey, I love every type of sword,
but this is the one type
of sword
that I know is not for me.
These type of
two-handed greatswords
were given to the largest,
tallest soldiers
to guard banners.
They were sometimes
called Doppelsoldners.
In armored duels, they would
use it with immense --
absolutely immense
swiping motions.
But you can't stand
and fence with it.
This is a weapon that you're
gonna be covering and guarding,
and there's a lot of opportunity
to bind and trap.
This is a weapon
for you guys.
Yeah, my God.
That's --
This is the heaviest weapon
of this entire competition
that I've put in my hands.
The blade -- it's a flamberge,
flambergé, flammard, flambard --
"flame blade" --
and the belief is that
the, uh,
waves or the flame portion
is an attempt to combine the
slicing power of a curved blade
with the versatility
of a straight blade.
Hmm.
Flame blades like this
were actually
on many different types
of swords,
from arming swords to side
swords to even rapiers.
And there's even an Indonesian,
uh, blade called the kris knife,
that uses the same pattern
and principle.
Right.
So, one of things that I like
about, uh, this sword --
we talked about
longswords in melee
and how in our sport,
they're not as effective
'cause you don't feel the --
the blows.
This, you're gonna feel
the blows of.
You have the ability
to have a wider grip on this.
This is gonna give you
more power.
You're gonna get more torque
over it,
more control
over this weapon.
You can choke up
if you need to.
But imagine if somebody's got
a long arm length,
and they get to put this out --
fire blows from afar.
You're gonna see some --
some real big swings here.
Wait, wait, wait.
But it has an amazing,
amazing balance
that it's still a maneuverable
weapon for its size and weight.
I mean, just to put that
in perspective, I'm 6'1".
Right?
Yeah, that's 6-foot.
Look at the size
of this weapon.
That's 6-foot tall.
♪♪